la conciliation te permet de mettre fin
à un différend
ce peut être un problème de voisinage de
nuisance un problème commercial
également aux et concilier d'offres sont
en fait des auxiliaires de justice qui
sont bénévoles
donc qu'ils peuvent être actifs loués ou
retraités et qui sont assermentés à la
cour d'appel donc de dix jours c'est un
service qui est gratuit c'est important
de le rappeler
ils sont recrutés en fonction de leur
expérience professionnelle et en
particulier il faut avoir exercé dans le
domaine du droit pendant au moins 3 a
mené à une application nationale
conciliateur de justice point.fr est là
et il va trouver les lieux de
rendez-vous des différents conciliateur
il ya 2149 saisie c'est à dire des
personnes qui donc ont demandé donc à
ouvrir un dossier nous sommes 1200
conciliateur en france et pour vous
donner une idée ça fait à peu près le 3
conciliateur pour cent mille habitants
donc on arrive à un tour du réseau
58e
ce qui est déjà important c'est une
premier rendez vous donc une affaire
nouvelle et j'ai invité le défendeur
c'est-à-dire l'autre partie à venir en
réunion de conciliation pour dialoguer
avec son voisin ce qui n'est pas gagné
d'avancé mais c'est une tentative
préalable indispensable et obligatoire
avant de citer au tribunal